so hey you guys movie retrospective time
once again and once again going back to
the 1970s yep and talking about good old
michael creighton michael crichton once
again
even though you know what okay so this
movie i was thinking like before we
recorded this i was just like how funny
would it have been if we had just
recorded this whole video with both of
us just like sitting there like sleeping
like we were in comas that would be
super funny
like no one would watch it but it would
just be it it'd be funny conceptually
that's the kind of thing
michael craig
well see i saw this movie like when i
was a kid or like a teenager
and i had always been under the mistaken
assumption that it was based on a
michael crichton novel
and it's not good because he usually did
that like he usually like westworld and
all that kind of stuff but but this was
actually from a novel by robin cook who
was like a friend of his okay now
michael crichton did write the
screenplay and he did direct it so
that's probably why i had that
misconception it's it's a michael
crichton movie anyway it is yeah he may
have well has written the book
it's the same kind of story the same
kind of thing he did what he would do is
um
he connor wrote
disaster
movies which that was
that was avant-garde at the time real
popular but it always had a tech
spin to it he was always trying to show
the public new science and technology
[ __ ] that was like uh
an experimental
uh a prototype phase and how it would
impact the world you know westworld was
one of them um
let's see jurassic park
yeah he did jurassic park did yeah yeah
and then uh what was some of the
andromeda drama stream
[ __ ] there was just a little oh a
[ __ ] runaway with [ __ ] thompson
that's the app yeah he did uh
what was the one with the gun that would
[ __ ] blind you and [ __ ] make you
forget uh you had down looker looker
when that yeah looker i think that might
have been creighton too yeah it was
michael crichton where they're
scientifically measuring the anatomical
proportions of [ __ ] women to find out
who'd be the most popular supermodel
remember that they were trying to
it's about advertising campaigns and
technology going bad which is kind of
funny because like yeah we have those
now they're called [ __ ] video game
characters
you know the
thing is is they don't sell anything cg
doesn't really work that well but back
in those days they thought
if they thought if a woman was of a
certain proportions perfect proportions
that you could use
to sell products and the products that
sell like crazy but now she just ends up
looking like a generic supermodel yeah
you know what's better is a famous
person that has [ __ ] outlandish
proportions he'll sell more you know
we're in the air of tna but it was
always like that
and just you know like in heroin addicts
that sold products for a while
that's true so but anyway this is a
movie that's kind of like that um but
it's about the the medical industry
and
some of it
some of it kind of accurate the medical
industry
kind of doing
doing bad things to make a bunch of
profits and money and
corruption inside the medical industry
and this one's about a damn developing
this facility to store people in comas
or people who are in comas how to keep
them from wasting away so they're
perfect when they come out of their coma
no that's not what it is that's what it
seemed like no that was what the
technology was for though wouldn't it no
they were harvesting their organs
okay yeah but it was a way of storing a
person who was in a coma though right
yeah but that the reason they were
storing them is because is because they
were going to sell their organs to the
highest bidder okay
i didn't think that they were all alert
i didn't think they were all gonna do
that i thought yeah yeah that well
that's why because there's okay so this
movie it's interesting because like i
said it's based on a book by robin cook
now robin cook and michael creighton
were friends they're both surgeons
the interesting thing about robin cook
um you know he was a surgeon and then he
was like well i you know i wanted to be
a novelist on the side like michael
crichton was um but he actually stayed
being a doctor whereas michael crichton
after he was really successful he was
like [ __ ] it i'm just gonna like write
books from now on but robin cook stayed
a doctor so i think like when they
robin cook wrote one book at first like
that was all about medical interns and
stuff and uh it didn't really do all
that well like nobody gave a [ __ ] like
you know the critics kind of didn't like
it and nobody bought it
so then he very specifically went and
read a whole bunch of other best sellers
and like took all these notes about how
they were structured and all this other
kind of stuff and then he wrote coma
and it came out in 1977 and it was a
massive massive success and i think like
even before it was published like
because him and michael crichton were
friends he michael crichton was like oh
okay i'm gonna buy the rights to this
and we'll make it because like i said
they were friends they were both
surgeons and
one thing that they wanted though and
i don't think that this uh was
completely successful but because they
were both doctors they said well we want
to make this like a scary thriller
where some of the doctors are bad guys
but we don't want to like we wanted to
be scary but we don't want to like turn
people off the medical profession like
as a whole because they were doctors and
it's like you know most people are gonna
have to go to a doctor at some point in
their life and we don't want everybody
being terrified that like we're gonna
drug them and like take their organs and
[ __ ] like that um although i did say
like the wikipedia page said that a
couple of things like that did happen
they said that like one operating like
one hospital in tampa actually had to
change they had an or8 which is kind of
like a big thing in this movie if you've
seen it and they had to change the the
number on that operating room because
people were like oh no i'm not going in
there you know what i mean so yeah it's
that kind of thing yeah the okay just in
general michael crichton movies they're
okay uh they tend to have convoluted
plots if you ask me they tend to kind of
have slow starts and they tend to be
boring by today's standards just
telling the truth some of them are
really good like andromeda strain i love
it but the average person would find
that boring i think i think a lot of his
70s ones are kind of slow and this one's
kind of slow although it picks up like
in the third actor and uh westworld was
pretty good but i think if you were to
show that to your average [ __ ] 16 70
to 18 year old they would just yawn
through the whole thing i mean none of
that none of that technology even phases
them there just doesn't matter you know
and that
so
that
this one i had a hard time paying
attention to it uh i thought it was
convoluted kind of boring and slow
especially in the beginning it got
better as it went and it started
to i guess become interesting but it was
kind of too late for me i had kind of
mentally checked out like i didn't
really even know exactly what the
technology was for yeah they're
harvesting organs yeah i just thought
they were harvesting organs out of those
but i thought that that was also
available for people who were customers
who were in comas and wanted to be
kind of like
good if they ever came out of the coma
because that thing was moving them
remember
yeah i know that keeping them in good
condition
and they were saying it cost what 40 a
day to be in there i'd imagine i was
thought that what i thought what they
were inferring is that you'd have like a
walt disney type dude going in there
having his head frozen or whatever and
when he came out of the coma he'd be all
right you know no i mean the only reason
that they were keeping those people
alive at all for it was for the art was
for the organs
and that was why okay so the story about
this i want to say too that like this
actually has this has a great [ __ ]
cast okay um genevieve uh boujold
plays the lead and she's fantastic in
this i feel like
this was i know she was in because i
know her from dead ringers which was
like a later that was 88 but i knew
she'd been like a bunch of stuff before
this i think she played like anne boleyn
and that was kind of like her big thing
like a few years before this but she's
really really great in this
interestingly uh so she plays the lead
doctor like susan wheeler
and even though isn't this interesting
even though the book character is also a
woman uh and that's kind of like a big
part of the plot when they were making
it into a movie the producers were like
no no we have to we it has to be a man
and they wanted paul newman
and michael crichton is like uh the main
character in the book is a woman though
and it kind of has a lot to do with the
plot
so he stuck to his guns and i'm glad he
did because i think that worked out
really well
yeah but this also is an early film role
for michael douglas yeah he's young
i mean he was not that young
30-something he was famous at this point
because he'd been on streets of san
francisco you know the tv show
um and i think he'd been in a few movies
before this but this was kind of like
he's not the lead but because he just
plays like you know he it's a big part
but he just plays like the boyfriend of
dr wheeler and sporty character he's
like a supporting character uh this also
has richard widmark in it and uh
little uh cameo by tom selleck he plays
one of the uh coma victims that they put
in the coma and did you notice ed harris
was in this which who's ed harris ed
harris was in creep show he was in kind
of he was in like all kind of crap
um yeah you'd know him if you saw him
you know if he saw him the first thing i
thought of was he was in creep show but
he was also in um i think he was a
leviathan he wasn't like a bunch of
stuff and uh he this might have been i
don't think it was his first first movie
but he has like a like a couple speaking
lines like he plays like a pathologist
or something um also lois childs is in
this and i think she was in a james bond
movie later um after this so this is
kind of like an all-star cast
so
genevieve boujold she works at she's
like a medical resident at i think at
boston memorial is the name of the
hospital right i don't even know if
that's a real hospital or not but yeah
so she works there
and uh so her boyfriend she's dating
like another doctor their doc i think
his name is dr bellows or something like
bellows
is it dr bella
that's a [ __ ] i drew well i know it
is but it might have been it was
something like that it was something
like that i kind of feel like
um most of these characters just kind of
came and went to me
it is dr bella that's what i thought
that's what i thought because i kind of
laughed like i was like oh dr bellows
that's pretty funny but yeah that is his
name in the movie i'm not just like
making it up but yeah so
uh so they're kind of going out but
they're kind of having problems i guess
because um you know she's works really
hard and he works really hard and she's
like you know why don't you ever cook
dinner like clean up around here because
i'm working just as long as you are and
he's like getting cranky like give me a
beer blah blah blah so there's all that
kind of stuff going on at the beginning
so a lot of the stuff at the beginning
and i think what you were saying
um is kind of just like establishing
their relationship and establishing this
kind of stuff which does play into it
later on because i think that's sort of
like the emotional core of the story i
guess but i found it a little bit slow
as well but i you know i didn't mind it
that much because i really do like those
two actors and i think that michael
douglas and uh genevia boujold had
really good chemistry with one another
so i think it was like a good uh thing
like setting up their relationship see i
think this is the problem with the
movies
they they were having unique challenges
they're trying to tell a story and build
up to some kind of exciting reveal or
trippy reveal around a technology
that the audience is not real familiar
with yet and they don't they haven't
even really thought about the the
ramifications of these technologies it's
in every one of these michael crichton
flicks
well
that usually means that you have to make
the
audience uh feel well grounded and
normal like they're in a normal reality
and then you got to keep ratcheting it
up like keep revealing things about this
technology and then what how it could be
abused and how it could [ __ ] go wrong
and all that kind of stuff
and uh nowadays
movies like this can be so it could be
summed up very quickly and they wouldn't
phase a modern audience
yeah but i mean this was 1978 1978. and
the thing about this as far as michael
crichton movies in general go
this one leans less into the technology
aspect and more i mean it's a medical
thriller pretty much
um you know and that comes from the book
and
so i don't know i i feel like even
though the first part of this does have
a lot of like medical jargon because he
wanted it to be i mean he's a surgeon
the guy that wrote the book is a surgeon
so they wanted it to seem as realistic
as possible and with the way that the
doctors talk to one another and the way
that they acted and stuff was actually
very um they want credibility and
authenticity right you know which it's
all setting the stage and trying to set
the tone so you buy it later on when
right right right that's what they're
doing yeah uh
like i said these are very techy very
sciencey
and yeah it is very jargon
but that's how doctors talk yeah and
crichton films are always kind of coming
from a position of [ __ ] authority you
know what i mean in a way it's like yeah
check this out i'm showing you what's
really happening check out this weird
[ __ ] think about that you know it they
were good they were good i'm not saying
they were bad
most of them were kind of like disaster
flicks which were popular at the time
it's just that like i said the the
the tech is dated by today's standards
so it's not going to have the same
effect you'd have to do it yeah that's
true nowadays it'd all be about virtual
reality and weird kinds of genetic
engineering and transhumanism that's
what it would be today but the thing
about this one you have that on black
mirror but the thing about this one
though is i think what i was going to
say was that i think this one actually
maybe um
maybe dated a little bit better
just because it wasn't as tech reliant
as something like westworld was right
because this one i mean they still i
mean people still need organ transplants
right um so even though some of the
medical technology is dated because this
came out in the 70s um you know the the
problem of like still needing organ
transplants that's still a real thing
and so it's still kind of a thing that
you might think there's some nefarious
shady little cabal of doctors that are
being like hey this person has a kidney
that we need let's put them in a coma
and then we'll take it you know what i
mean so it's not as dated as something
as some of his more technological stuff
would yeah isn't it called black mirror
yeah yeah there's that series nowadays
something like this would just be a
black mirror episode that's how they
would do it today but they were really
cool in the day they were full-length
features i mean this this really and
we've talked about this because we've
covered like a lot of other like 70s
like political conspiracy theories maybe
we just talked about like blow out the
other day and the 70s were really big
you know because of all the kennedy
assassination and mlk assassination and
you know uh
and all that kind of stuff yeah and
vietnam and watergate and all that kind
of stuff so like the 1970s audiences
really liked stuff about conspiracies
and this movie is essentially about um
it's a medical conspiracy not
necessarily a political conspiracy but
it's kind of like the same thing but so
people like it today too man that shit's
still [ __ ] big and you know i'm just
saying that you saw it that you saw it a
lot like in a lot of big movies it's not
mainstream anymore because they they
wanted to stop that they didn't want you
questioning [ __ ] them you know so
they came up with conspiracy theorists
and [ __ ] like that that's cia
yeah and once you [ __ ] talk about
that
but the thing about this one that i
think is really interesting is that
i don't know i just really like the
character that genevieve uh boujole
plays so like i said she starts getting
suspicious about this hospital where she
works
when her friend
goes in for she's going to get an
abortion right and she just goes and
it's supposed to be like i said like
just a regular you know surgical
procedure and they put her under
anesthetic and she never wakes up even
though she's very very young and very
healthy and nobody can really figure out
like why she went into a coma
and they she basically goes brain dead
and you know she's like wigging out
about it because it's like her best
friend and she's like that's really
really weird like why did that happen
and so she's pretty suspicious about
that but you know you could write that
off you know that was her best friend
and she was really upset about it and
you know she couldn't really deal with
the fact that this girl just died like
randomly but then it seems to happen
again tom selleck comes in
and like obviously like not the actual
tom selleck but so tom selleck comes in
and he was just getting something he was
just getting some kind of like surgery
like on his leg like he had a broken
ankle or some [ __ ] like that i don't
even remember what it was but um yeah so
he just comes in for a reaching thing
and then he goes in a coma as well and
he's also very young and very healthy
and at this point dr wheeler is like
what the [ __ ] is going on in here like
why are these people
going into comas and so she starts like
asking around about it and the man like
one of the head doctors is like yeah but
you know this hospital does what like
300 000 surgeries every year like every
now and then you know 10 you know if it
happens 10 times in a year that's not
really that weird which is true like
statistically that's not that weird so i
like that they kind of had this thing
where there was still like plausible
deniability like it could just be
that yeah like [ __ ] happens that's
completely possible but she slowly
starts to become convinced that she's
like no i really think there's something
going on and then she goes and like
talks to the pathologist and is like you
know just hypothetically
if i wanted to put somebody into a coma
from which they would not awaken and
didn't really want any evidence of it
left behind like what would i do what
would you do if you were me so she kind
of asked the pathologist and they're
like um you know and they're kind of
coming up with all these scenarios
they're like oh you know what would be
the best way to do it carbon monoxide
like put carbon monoxide like into the
into the
thing that they're breathing through and
that wouldn't really leave any trace or
anything like that so she's like
so she ends up like finding out that
carbon monoxide is possibly being piped
into this one operating room which is
or8 um but not all the time and that's
the thing that
people start thinking she's crazy
because her she tells her boyfriend
about all this michael douglas and he's
like okay well we're gonna go look at
the you know because they work at the
hospital they're doctors so they can go
in there and check it out so they go in
there and she's like oh everything looks
fine but she's still like really
suspicious and yeah it turns out that
they only do it sometimes like if
somebody that's real young and healthy
comes in and like i said they have like
a compatible organ that you know
whoever's bidding on all the organs is
you know needs
then they'll be like oh let's they flag
it and then they'll kill this person or
put them in a coma and then they send
them to this place called the jefferson
institute and then they keep them
hanging up because i think that's kind
of like the most iconic image from this
movie is that big huge room like full of
all those people scantily clad and
they're hanging yeah and the thing about
it is that you know this was 1978 they
didn't have no special effects to do
that so they actually had to get a bunch
of extras and like hang them there yeah
and they said they could really only
keep them like that for six or seven
minutes at a time so because it was like
you know they had to like stay still
because they're in comas and uh yeah so
they hung them all in there and just
they had to like keep just filming a
little bit and then stop and film a
little bit and stop and like let them
down i just remember the cover of the
book man yeah grocery store and check
out
all this looking people hanging over i
think there's just one person hanging by
yeah that's a great poster actually it's
very minimalist but i really really like
that
i think it was just i think it was white
it was white i don't remember the book
cover but i ended up hanging yeah the
dude was just hanging like from all
these like laying flat yeah yeah and
it's just like a great image but that's
why
the jefferson institute is this place
where
they hang all these bodies there and
they're all alive but they're all in
comas they're all brain dead because
that's you know they do that to them on
purpose you got a computer monitor them
and moving them so they don't atrophy
and stuff yeah they didn't what they
didn't want to get bed sores or like
anything like that like from laying
wires so they just hang them up so
they're just like suspended and then
whenever um you know the
they have kind of like auctions i guess
they're like hey who needs this kidney
or this liver or whatever and it's like
they'll pay you know hundred thousand
dollars or whatever the sum is and then
they'll be like oh yeah we got one like
over here in the
in the hangi thing and they just go and
like pop it and like sell it to somebody
so you know so that's kind of what the
whole conspiracy was because obviously
that was what the conspiracy was now not
everybody at the hospital was in on it
but kind of like the main one of the
main doctors who she thought was her
friend actually he was kind of the guy
that was behind it and he was the one
that had set up the jefferson institute
and all that kind of stuff but it was
all just for making money from selling
organs like on the black market
essentially so that's what they were
doing um but yeah i mean this was i now
we were watching this movie last night
and i had been up since like 3 30 in the
morning so i was like really tired and i
think that i managed to watch it but i
think i dozed off a couple times
but i don't think i didn't miss all that
much because then i went and like read
the plot synopsis and everything like
that i'm like okay i got all that so
you know what i mean but i will say if
you like
kind of conspiracy thrillers uh from the
70s if you like medical thrillers if you
like michael crichton's other stuff um
then this is a good one it's not the
best one of his i've seen i mean i
prefer westworld um even though that's
less even though like i said it's dated
more than this one andromeda strain
yeah i don't know i don't know i like
andromeda strain too but i can't decide
which one i like better i might like
this one better we were talking about
all the stuff that he did do while we
were watching the movie and i would then
i was like did he do china
syndrome you know what i don't know
maybe
sounds like i always get it
it definitely sounds like something that
he would have done i don't know if he
did it i saw it as a kid i can't
remember yeah boring
so maybe he did do it yeah
had jane fonda in it and jack lemmon
that's right yeah i'm gonna have to look
that up again he very well may have
because it did sound like something that
was kind of like what would happen in
his wheelhouse yeah if the [ __ ] core
melts down and it goes down to burn yeah
see that sounds like something to the
water table
whatever yeah [ __ ] make enough steam
and [ __ ]
burn its way down to china
like digging to china that is like all
that i think is what they were talking
about yeah they probably weren't that
that hot core would burn its way to
china yeah [ __ ] gravity
go right to the core and keep on going
well i mean they didn't really think
about it all that much
[Laughter]
but yeah so that's the thing i kind of
feel like this movie i really liked this
one and i really like the acting
performances and stuff like that but it
is pretty slow
and jargon heavy for like the first
two thirds i would say
like once the conspiracy really starts
rolling because it takes a while i mean
she kind of gets onto it because her
friend dies
and she's like huh that's weird and so
she starts like asking questions and
stuff but it doesn't really get to a
point where you know uh where she kind
of becomes a target of conspiracies
where people start like following her
and [ __ ] like real nefarious [ __ ] starts
happening like it takes a while to get
to that point but once it gets to the
third act i really really liked it
because then it becomes kind of like a
race against time because you know the
doctor like drugs her and is gonna take
her kidneys or whatever the [ __ ] like
he's gonna do that he's gonna comb her
as well so and then like the boyfriend
has to you know nut up and like save her
and
turn off the gas and all this other kind
of stuff like up in the cause they have
it like up in this attic thing or up in
the i don't know like it's up in the
well i want to say it's up in the bowels
bells are down but it's just it's up in
the lake top up in the top bowels of the
hospital where they have like this thing
that uh you know that they have like on
a i think it's like a radio transmitter
or something like that that like tells
them you know oh let's do the carbon
monoxide today because they don't do it
to everybody so so yeah i will say that
it's not the best michael crichton i've
seen but i don't think it's the worst
it's not a bad made movie yeah it's
actually really well made i think and it
had like i said it had a great cast it's
jerry goldsmith
it made a [ __ ] ton of money i think it
only cost like four or five million to
make and it made like 50 or 60 million
back like it was a big success
yeah it's just a little slow and it's
kind of the topic matters kind of dated
a little bit and it's just
if you're a michael crichton fan yeah
then you should definitely see it then
you should definitely see it like i said
i think it's one of his ones from the
70s that
um that has
not dated as much
as something like runaway or something
like that which obviously you know is
ridiculous i mean yeah which seeing it
now is like ridiculous but you can watch
that and actually laugh at it that's
true just because of how it predicts
this one because it's a lot more
realistic and like i said it's having to
do with something that still goes on
like organ theft um you know that's
still a thing so
it's not as dated as some of his other
stuff if you guys don't know what
runaway is it's tom selleck it's a
response to robocop i think
michael crichton
tom selleck is a [ __ ] cop who's
supposed to be hunting down [ __ ]
robots that have gone [ __ ] crazy and
when you see the robots he's talking
about [ __ ] the printer
talking about printers and dishwashers
it looks like a printer on a [ __ ]
other [ __ ] on wheels
uh uh robots that [ __ ] plant plants
and it's just the robots are not a
threat yeah i think we did a review we
did a review of it a while back and i
think i said i think about it as [ __ ]
the killer facts machine like coming
back or something like that and then
eventually eventually he's got to fight
an army of [ __ ] ants made out of
looked like a made out of erector set
and what that was that was the one that
was the one that had what's his face
from kiss in it too
as the villain gene simmons was actually
the best part of the movie he was
actually he's actually a good he's a
good villain yeah uh
but no that runaway is
runaway would make a great rift tracks
or a [ __ ] really good really good rip
tracks or mst
that's what i'm saying and that's just
because and that's just because that one
like the technology and that one just
like looks so laughably dated whereas
this one doesn't really have that
problem like i said because the only
things that are dated in this are kind
of like some of the medical things that
they do and you know
is in a [ __ ] blue suit with chain
mail armor and [ __ ] reflective grids
with a laser gun
doing [ __ ] imt in combat roles trying
to fight against basically a printer
with wheels that can shoot a [ __ ]
i'm pretty i'm i'm 99 sure that's an
actual printer i think it was a printer
i made it look like it's just looking
ridiculous
[Laughter]
yeah at least with robocop you know they
had tentacles and [ __ ] legs and feet
and faces and they could talk and [ __ ]
these things could talk but it was just
like
your cell phone is far more powerful
than the robots yeah nobody really saw
any of that kind of stuff yeah but yeah
i'm going to say uh yeah so if you've
seen combo let me know i actually they
did a mini series of like a two-part
mini-series um on a e back in 2012 of
coma so it's like another adaptation of
the book i don't know if it's any good
or not but you know if you've seen it
let me know like i said this is
you know i i didn't love it but i
thought it was pretty good i just think
i think it took a while to get going but
i really did like i think genevieve
boujold was my favorite part of it well
i like her anyway like i said she was
really good at dead ringers and michael
douglas is great so all the acting is
really really good i just think it took
too long to like
get where it was going but once it got
where it was going i think i think it
was better i'll pass it i think it got a
lot better i'll pass i didn't like it as
much as cause i remembered seeing this
when i was younger and for some reason i
was just like ooh that was really scary
and like it's stuck in my head but i
didn't i don't know why necessarily but
i don't know maybe there's just
something about the the
concept of it that i really liked but
yeah yeah anyways it's on hbo max so if
you want to watch it uh and you have hbo
max and you can probably watch it and if
you've seen it if you love it if you
hate it like let me know in the comments
and we will see you guys again on the
next retrospective bye